choose your own autobiography such a
great book and so many cool little ideas
in here too it's all little random
stories of things that I've done because
I have these crazy chapters from you
know Doogie Howser to dr. horrible to
Barney Stinson and opening the Tonys and
having babies and making out with dudes
and stuff so I thought a good structure
would become a as to make it a second
person thing so you are me in the book
so it's not your you get to choose what
you would like for me to do and you can
hop to different stories it's really
it's very imaginative it's very well
done as magic tricks there's magic
tricks it tells you actually if you want
to learn certain tricks there's drink
recipes there's a recipe for a drink
that we invented called how I wet your
mother
which is yeah tell us what that is it's
delicious okay there's a story you
telling here about a time when your
brother arranged for you when you were
much younger to make out with two girls
at the same time oh yeah yeah let's tell
that story cuz that's fascinating well
my brother Brian was three years older
than me so he was the one I would always
watch his crazy endeavors and he would
throw parties when my parents were away
as kids do and was so he was maybe 17
and threw a party with everyone drinking
wine coolers going crazy right and I was
three years younger and they played a
game called passed the gum where you'd
find some girl that you liked and you'd
give her gum and she chew the gum and
then you'd make out for a minute well if
it doesn't pass from one mouth to the
other right and so I got to play that
with a couple of girls and of his
friends and then two girls together
wanted to put their tongues in my mouth
what really yeah assassinating so I I
made out with two girls at the same time
when I was and I was a youngster but I
think in hindsight weirdly since they're
just using angles that they're both of
their tongues were definitely in my
mouth but I think my tongue was between
their cheeks
I don't remember kind of going left to
right
I remember being panicked and going
straight forward so I think it was it
was super fun for me and kind of
disgusting just envy you you've never
made out with two women at the same time
that's incredible
not yet you haven't
all right my wife is going to really get
behind this idea she can watch she would
totally not want to be one you go ahead
you